[Music]
you can talk about whatever you want man
I'm excited to have you back dude it's
good to see you
you too man thanks for thanks for coming
out man I appreciate it no I'm you know
you've done a lot for me man I really
just not just stuff that you've done for
me personally I mean you've always been
a you know even a good friend to mean
supportive but just do your guess as a
fan you know I mean I've learned so much
and it's just great to see how people
gravitate towards the you know does the
genuine you just genuine manner so I
there's a lot of snake oil out there
there's definitely a lot of snake oil
out there but I you know I don't know I
mean that's that's the thing that I'm
trying to be most conscious of all the
time like is this real like am I being
real or am i you know am I is there
artifice here that I need to strip away
from like you know the word authenticity
now has become so co-opted that I don't
even know what that means anymore but it
is true like I'm trying to just you know
I'm just trying to you know present
these people and ask them the questions
that I want to know the answers to and
that I think the audience wants to know
the answers to and just [ __ ] keep it
real now yeah you know yep so it's good
it's good to have you and there's been I
mean I was thinking like when I first
met you I went to your house in Atlanta
we didn't know each other really and I
didn't know what to expect we had a
great conversation but you've done a lot
since then I feel like at that moment in
time it was right on right at the
beginning of when living with the seal
was coming out yeah and and you were
kind of like oh okay entrepreneur who
like wrote this book and now I mean how
long ago was that three years ago three
years like that
now you've got this other book coming
out that I want to talk about but you've
kind of stepped into this world of like
like motivational groove guy you know
creating all these events like you're
really out like cultivating community
around these ideas in a way that you
weren't doing at that point in time
right like that's kind of an evolution
for you it has been a process and like
many things in my life that wasn't
planned I didn't
planet I didn't you know I even the book
with with David
I didn't invite David to come live with
me and say okay we're gonna write it
above and I think it had been a totally
different outcome if that was the case
mmm he lived with me and it was an
amazing journey and I started sharing
the story and people are gravitating
towards like what makes a guy like that
tick mm-hmm and how do I get the secret
sauce and drive and consistency and
discipline of someone like that and and
ultimately it led to well let me share
that and the same thing with this whole
kind of I don't know if I would call it
I definitely call it guru or but
motivation or whatever it's just honesty
it's like this is how I live my life and
if people are into it let me give you a
look inside under the hood of you know
how I live my life I think I live it
differently than others but it's just
how I want to live it you know did you
make a conscious decision like okay I'm
gonna start sharing this stuff or was it
because people were responding to you in
a different way or like how did that
evolve it started like anything else
super small like my wife always says
start small think big and scale fast in
business and this was the same kind of
thing friends would come to my house and
they would be like this was an amazing
day like I can't believe and I'm like I
do this every day you know this is what
I do I you know we get up we have a good
healthy meal we work out we we you know
we talk about stuff we live as big and
as fun and as happy as we possibly can
and of course there's hiccups and I'm
like wow this you know like you want
more of this come over again and then
like more people would come and but when
it's your normal you're just like well
this is this is it isn't everybody doing
this right and you don't realize until
you invite those other people over the
contrast between how you're living
versus other people like I get a little
bit of that just you know we live a
pretty unique kind of non-traditional
you know life here here you got a little
idea of that but when you're dizzy
sleeping it's just my normal thing but
I'm like yeah everybody should do that
that's a little bit different I think
when I first spoke to you if it just
been made public that David Goggins was
the guy in the book because in living
with seal you never name
right and there was some question as to
whether you were ever gonna be able to
like say who it was specifically and
it's been interesting over the last
couple years and maybe just even in the
last year alone how David has made this
kind of conscious effort to step out
into the public eye and share his story
in a real way I mean I was able to get
him on the podcast and now I've seen
he's done a bunch of shows and it's
working on a book and all that kind of
stuff so that's been kind of cool to see
too because yeah as you know and as I
you know knew going way back I'm like
this guy needs to like share what easy I
you know like people don't realize when
he's sitting on top of so right it's and
then when he goes and he does these
shows people are just like what you know
I didn't even wrap their head around it
yeah well you know I think people are so
myself included we get caught in our own
routine and what happened at least in my
own life is time goes really fast when
you're in the routine and you're doing
the same thing over and over and before
you know it you wake up and you're 70 or
80 you know like oh man I can't climb
that mountain that I wanted to climb
anymore and well you know when you see
people that are doing something
differently and you gravitate towards
that and you change time slows down you
feel super alive and you know his story
is so compelling I mean it's it's so
interesting a how he thinks and how he
approaches life but I think anyone like
that has a different outlook that gives
you a little bit of nugget of wisdom
that helps you improve can really you
know have changed the affect then on how
you live we were just talking about it a
minute ago before we started the podcast
of how I'm turning 50 and the thing
that's fundamentally shifted for me as I
turned 50 is my relationship with time
and I think that people we think of
relationships in terms of my
relationship with my family my kids my
wife my parents but we don't think of
relationships in terms of money and time
and you know my relationship with time
was out of whack and as I turned 50 I
realized like man the average American
lives to be 78 now I hope I'm not
average but that's a fact and if I am
the average I got 28 summers left and my
summers between 70 and 80 are going to
be
you know my relevant year shrink
dramatically as a percentage every year
I get older so I'm not gonna be able to
do it I love to do what makes me tick
that's hopefully I will but likely I
didn't see a lot of people doing
100-mile run I did that were seventy
five years old yeah I got 28 if you have
28 summers it's like well who do you
want to spend that time with and had
what do you want to do and it's like
something happened as I'm turning 50
that I'm so damn aware of it that
literally literally it's in my DNA it's
like every night I go to sleep I'm like
that I maximize the day you know and
like Jesse man you got you know if you
have 28 years left what in the world do
you want to accomplish before that time
is up mm-hmm you know so I've had this
fundamental shift and it's [ __ ] with
me but what I think is interesting about
you is I mean first of all I would agree
like for me you know 40 was what it was
but like 50 is a different deal you know
and it really hit me at 51 like we were
talking for the podcast like Mike my
hair start gaunt gray like immediately
and my back's a little tight you know
it's like it's the first instance of
experiencing you know any kind of aging
because I always just feel like I'm 24
or whatever and for the most part I
still feel that way but it is you know
I've found it to be significant but I
think what's what's what's unique about
you is look you you live your life in
you know a pretty unique set of
circumstances like you can [ __ ] do
whatever you want right and most people
who are you know in your scenario are
just chilling you know like they're
going on nice vacations and they're just
relaxing and they're not continuing to
push themselves so like what is it
inside of you that's always like trying
you know that that like impulse till I
continually grow and put yourself in
uncomfortable situations and expand your
horizons well I think I'm driven from me
I'm a big believer in building your life
resume versus your personal red I mean
having a business resume is important
but I think a life resume is a real good
look of your own of your real body of
work it's a real indication of who you
are and what you're becoming and I am
NOT nobody cares that the Dallas
Mavericks or won the championship five
years ago or that Alabama and the
football it's like what's next and
that's how I live my life it's like
check the box I don't want to sit and
dwell on the fact that okay Jesse you
ran this marathon or you completed you
sold this or whatever because tomorrow
no one cares about that
and so it's like check the box and move
on and that's that's it's like how can I
build build the biggest life resume that
I can build and those things and those
challenges and pushing myself again for
me is the only way to really know what
I'm made of it's where all the growth is
all the growth is there and it truly and
you know it truly in my heart of hearts
makes me feel the most alive it's what I
like to do and I didn't like it I
wouldn't do it I would just be like I'm
gonna go to a fancy hotel and sit in the
lobby and drink martinis but it requires
I think what it does is it it forces you
to confront yourself in a very humbling
way like it requires some humility
I salute like you gotta check your ego
at the door and you're you you know
you're in a situation where you could
just be feeding your ego all day long
right so so it's about like always
remembering like there's more to do
there's more to there's more to learn
like there's there's there's there's a
there's always a horizon that's a little
bit outside of your reach and if you
have the willingness to approach that
that's where some magic can happen for
yourself and that's where you feel alive
and that's where that you you do
experience that thing where time slows
down you do and I think you know I've
got plenty of regrets in my life if I
could go back they would say look what
would you tell you 21 year old self and
what would you do differently and
there's a lot of stuff it's easy to look
back and play Monday Morning Quarterback
and say this is what I was doing I have
a lot of regrets but from those lessons
it's like I don't want to have those
regrets I want to do as much as I can to
prevent that mm-hmm forward so you know
you only get what we all have the same
24 hours in a day yeah you're everybody
listening you myself it's just how do
you spend
and I'm super obviously you have to work
and you have to bring an income but you
get one life you know like you kid
there's no redo and I don't want to live
it like streamline like just a steady
line going across I want to kind of
always who doesn't want to live it with
an uptick I'm always trying to kind of
reach so that's why I love the
challenges and you good wired the same
way I mean yeah I think a lot of people
though think like they don't they don't
they consciously know they don't get a
redo but so many people and I'm guilty
of this this is the way I used to live
like you just sort of resign yourself to
how you're living and and there's some
part of you that does think like well
next time I'll do it differently this
idea that there is going to be a next
time it's you know the the reality of
like the 28 summers is like you know
that just puts it into perspective and
in a very real way yeah for and when you
start to realize your own like you're
you get in tune with your own mortality
like you start to realize that like in a
hundred years nobody that you see on the
street is gonna be here anymore
you know like first of all it's a great
motivator to get over fear cuz who cares
but we're all gonna be dead in like 80
years so like who cares what this guy
thinks about me you know but when you
start to realize that let's just take
the 28 summers I hope I'm wrong I hope I
live we all live longer but let's just
say that that is the case you know when
you look at it that way and it's a like
I have my parents are both alive
my parents are your parents alive how
will the appearance 76 74 and where do
they live Washington DC and how often do
you see him like twice a year okay so
most people like okay you know I have
let's say your parents live till 80 so
they have five more years okay let's
just say roughly you would say I have
five more years of my parents but I
would say no you have ten more times
with your parents if you see him twice a
year you see him twice a year times five
you have ten more times to see him when
you start thinking of things like that
your first reaction is I want to see my
parents
at least that's mine you know my parents
are 88 they live in Florida I live
Atlanta and I'm like I see him two times
a year I'm like man if they live to be
ninety one I'm gonna see them six more
times that's unacceptable to me so you
change the way you approaching them like
I'm gonna go see my parents every other
month you know I'm gonna make it a
priority and we don't think like that we
think ahead you know it's like nothing's
gonna happen it's always gonna be great
you know in two year we're going on a
vacation we're going here or I'm gonna
put it off I'm gonna do it next year
there's when you start to think
backwards you it creates insane urgency
at least it has for me you know and
that's what led me to the monastery I
was like like I'm not waiting five years
to do anything right right right I think
there's a watch that you can get that
counts down from I thought about that
the other day and I was like yeah that
would just freak me out though to be
always looking at it that way that could
that could make you neurotic too I think
it could and it's not like it's not like
I'm obsessed with the whole notion of
time and and and that and you could see
that you know you could think like that
could be depressing but for me it's
motivating mm-hmm and it's exciting but
we don't we don't think about death in a
healthy way
in our culture we just we pretend it's
not going to happen on some on some
level we all kind of think somehow we're
gonna avoid it yeah and and when it does
happen it makes us very uncomfortable we
don't know how to communicate around it
and and I feel like if we could if we
could bring awareness about our own
mortality into our daily existence which
is basically what you're you're saying
right now that it will allow us to
appreciate you know our days in a way
that we're challenged by right now I
think so very much so I think that's
part one I think part two is as we age
not like we're 90 rich conversation like
what 85 years old yes we have plenty of
great years left ahead of us but you
know one of my goals is to age with
vibrancy you know and not be medicated
and and restricted as I get into my 70s
and 80s you know I think I think the
average American I think there's four
billion prescriptions
prescribed every year second it's like
13 for every man woman and child in this
country or something something like that
is some outrageous number I think that
actually might be the stat and I'm not
I'm not a statistician but I would just
say by looking at my parents and their
inner circle a lot of that are till the
elderly blood thinners and this thing
and heart and pain and this and and it's
like why why just to sit you know like
my goal is to or one of my goals is to
just to live now in a way that will
allow me to be vibrant in the future and
the challenge is that you present to
yourself like always pushing yourself
and putting yourself in these
uncomfortable situations that that
creates that plasticity that that that
keeps you young I think it keeps you
engaged it keeps you you know vibrant
like you said and and I think that's you
know that's really the way if you if you
want like the recipe for youth you know
to be connected to other people to
cultivate community to put yourself in
these uncomfortable situations to the
extent that you can continue to do that
because it is it's it is about the
quality of the time that you're spending
it's not just getting old like how long
are you gonna live like what are those
last eight years gonna look like for you
yeah I mean exactly I mean that's 33% of
my life right you know left you know
it's a big I'm serious it's a big you
know you have to think like I think it's
important to think like that as opposed
to being in a bubble and living just you
know you plan everything else we plan so
far ahead you probably talked to your
wife what are we gonna do in Christmas
vacation you know what are we gonna do
like everything is forward but reverse
engineer it's no different than like
it's like when I was when I was starting
out in business and we had Mark any of
the ventures that I've been in I've
always had the the end of the movie in
my head the script had to be filled in
and the script might have rewrites along
the way but the end of the movie was
always crystal clear it's like okay this
is good you know there was no like B
plan this is what this is where we have
to get to and this was not let's figure
out let's figure this [ __ ] out and who
do we have to hire to get
there and what are we to do it's the
same thing with like kind of like life
right I mean like you know you want to
be 80 but what does 80 look like free
for rich roll yeah I think I need to do
a better job of that I mean you said to
me before the podcast like you know what
does your life look like in five years
and I was like I'm not sure I know
you're like oh I always have a crystal
clear view of you know what this is how
this is gonna work out at the end what
the end game looks like and I you know I
think I could I think I have a lot of
improvement in that regard because I I
don't tend to think in those terms
for starters tell yourself in five years
you know you're gonna be 35 years old
just here reverse reverse yeah that's
good yeah I think part of it is you know
like you mentioned part of the Fountain
of Youth is doing these challenges and
working out and being active and but how
much of your life is because you
forecasted five ten years ahead of time
like I feel like a lot like you just
said at the beginning like oh this is
all happening organically like now
you're being this motivational guy like
this wasn't a white boarded you know
agenda for you this is like a natural
organic outgrowth of the things that
you're just you're magnetized by that
you're interested in yeah so I mean I
didn't I didn't plan any of this I
didn't plan the living with the you know
the seal book and we're we're writing
books has taken me or speaking or any of
that stuff but now that I'm here and I
have a lane I have a vision and I'm
always kind of now I'm projecting out
three to five years like you know I'm
enjoying it first of all if it if it
doesn't resonate I'm out of here
and if I don't enjoy it I'm out of here
you know which goes to like when I look
at things like that I look at it like in
you know in a very very simple way risk
it aggravation vers reward if it's low
agri and we talked about this before the
podcast I was asking about your system
and everything it's like low aggravation
high reward is the target for anything
people work if it's high aggravation
high-reward when you're young that's
okay but as you get older you don't want
high aggravation in your life I like we
talked about this I could see it in your
face and you slept in a tent that's that
that's not an aggravating thing for me
at all but it's telltale computo so if
it becomes high aggravation then it
would be something that I would exit but
it wasn't planned but now that I have
this Lane I am projecting out three to
five years you know like what could it
be and how big could it be and what is
the vision well I have this little an
online coin I don't want this isn't
pitchy I'm just you asked I have an
online course so that's something I
think could scale and and that's
something I'm putting a lot of energy
into I enjoy speaking it's just staying
in the lanes that I like and making them
bigger right so you're going around
you're you're you're doing tons of talks
right traveling a lot doing a lot of
public speaking and like you do but you
could but you it's not just like you
show up and you give a speech like
you're going on runs with people and
you're taking them out into the out into
nature and having these experiences and
now you're creating these adventure
endurance challenge slash you know
wellness retreat like yeah again so
let's talk about that I mean I just in
the podcast that went up last night I
did I did a read for your you know the
new thing you're doing a maiden Denali
thing which yeah we're cool yeah it was
it's you know I've gained so much from
doing challenging things and I feel like
the same courage the same resilience and
persistence to accomplish a really tough
endurance event translates into business
parenting all the areas of your life
it's almost like it's almost like that's
the workout for all these other buckets
you know because it translates that grit
it doesn't disappear because the race is
over you can apply it to patients with
your kids and they are having a tantrum
or I mean they asked Richard Branson
what the what the the biggest key to his
success was and he said he said exercise
and I don't think he meant like
physically exercising I think he meant
the consistency the discipline going out
on days when it was raining when he
didn't want to do it you know the things
that that it takes during training and
this kind of stuff because it translates
into all into
your blood into your DNA so I did I
created this series of events the first
one was called 29 oh 29 which we rented
a the entire mountain of Stratton in
Vermont right which is crazy and brought
in tents which you would love because
you liked Four Seasons for you you'd
sleep in these tents you feel like come
sleep in these tents and we bring in
bands and food trucks but the challenge
was you know get up to the top of the
mountain it's Stratton take the gondola
down repeat until you climb the vertical
equivalent of Everest 29,000 29,000 plus
feet and so now we've created a summit
series of all the seven summits but
similar kind of themes the next one
being in Utah which is the equivalent of
Denali right so you're gonna go up this
mountain in Utah yeah do it nine times
right yes 2.3 miles 420 thousand three
hundred and twenty-two feet yeah yeah
yeah it's cool like I know that my
friend Colin over 80 did the one in
Stratton right yeah as an insane athlete
he did he win it early I mean he's first
of all I met him on the mountain uh-huh
I didn't nobody met him before now and
didn't know much about him and I met him
at around 11 o'clock at night it's pitch
dark it's windy it's cold I'm on the top
almost at the top of the mountain and I
see a light a headlight behind me of
maybe like a hundred yards but coming
like a mountain goat approaching me like
he's like a leopard you know and I turn
around I'm like is that a human you know
like who is that and he came over and
started talking and introduced himself
and slowed down tremendously and told me
his story which is fascinating amazing
backstory and then one on his merry way
until the light disappeared right I
think by the time I got finally to the
top of the summit he had already circled
down on the gondola came back and caught
me again it's continued continue the
conversation
yeah he was super impressive yeah well
you're doing this Syria you're gonna do
you're gonna do an event for each one of
the Seven Summits this is the guy
who has a world record for the fastest
to do all of those yeah in a year yes
yes so he's the perfect dude and I was
picking his brain like the whole time
I'm like you know what's the best way
for me you know it's like part of these
things are social you meet amazing
people like he and I became really close
after the event and I learned so much
from him and others because what I love
about this we've almost created a new
category endurance hiking is despite the
fact that it's low-impact which for me I
want right now I'm you know I'm craving
stuff that's not gonna pound my limbs
and have done all that and it's totally
doable my wife you know did 12 of the 17
summits but it's really social because
when the gondola is going down it's
going over the course you see you see
everybody the whole time and you get a
chance to really meet some interesting
people and he would he was one of them
and you also have like this it's it's
not just the event like you do this
immersive weekend and you bring bands
and speakers and yeah like for the thing
for the one in Utah I mean it sounds
almost like a wellness retreat yeah so
the day before we married a wellness
retreat with an endurance challenge and
I just feel like you know a lot of these
events out there races included are
they're all kind of similar
you know like here's a 10k but okay you
go and you do the thing and then you go
home you go home and I just wanted to
put a twist on it so why not have
speakers around people that run a 10k
would want like let's have let's have
someone talk about recovery let's have
someone talk about nutrition let's have
a mindset expert you know come in and
talk about how to keep going when you
want to stop so that's the theme yeah
that's cool so how many people can you
can you take for these events like how
many can you manage we we keep it kind
of tight we keep it limited to about 200
because yeah yeah it's small but not
small because um it just that's kind of
a it's kind of a sweet spot if it
becomes too big it becomes not as
special and not as intimate in my
opinion you know if we scale it down the
road but right now that's that's seems
to be working well yeah I like that I
like the community aspect of it
you know like you go and it's a bit you
do all the training and you show up and
then sometimes you know whether it's an
Ironman or a marathon like you're you're
with all these people but there's such
an amazing opportunity to connect more
deeply with everybody that I did gets
missed there's no bond like suffering
through a race anything ultras do
because you're there for so long and
there they tend to be smaller that you
get to really know those people a little
bit but yeah I think an ultra is at
least the one that a couple that I ran
it's so individualized like people
aren't like chatting it up and like
you're in your own world and this is
wait this is way more social from the
one from the event that we did in
Vermont nine of the of the nine of the
participants that didn't know each other
have come together and are now all
running Leadville this summer training
together having monthly dinners together
so a lot and that's my intent my intent
is to kind of bring people together did
this grow out of you used to maybe you
still do this thing where you do this
he'll run thing like it out in the
Hamptons or something like that like
kernel of inspiration for these yes I'm
just so bored with traditional races you
know it's like I'm just so bored with
obstacle runs and not knocking them I'm
just bored of mera that's why I go to
tiller last year yeah so different it's
just different so I have an event at my
house called hell on the hill it's for
charity and when you run up and down
this super steep incline hill which is
my backyard a hundred times takes about
three hours and it's brutal it's so
brutal but uh that was the genesis of
this and it's kind of like okay well
what are the themes good to a real
mountain yeah like the hill is not big
enough about growing the hill let's go
rent a mountain uh-huh yeah cool man
well let's let's talk a little bit about
the new book I mean I it comes out and
it doesn't come out for another month or
so a month and a half or something but I
was aware that you went you you you went
to this monastery so you get like living
with living with the monks living with
monks yeah what's going with the monks
uh-huh
so walk me through this like this is the
sequel to living with a seal yeah I
think you know I did the physical part
with Goggins and living with the seal
and now I wanted to just get into this
spiritual side a little bit which is
completely new to me mm-hmm I don't hurt
I've seen you sit down that was very
difficult for me as was being away from
my family but yeah I went to a lived on
a monastery for 15 days with eight
months four of which have been there for
50 years mmm 50 years and there was no
you know no cell phone no internet no
wife none of that stuff a silent retreat
it was there were periods of silence but
it wasn't it wasn't all silent and they
weren't Buddhist they were Russian
Orthodox right which I didn't even it's
kind of like a weird how did you select
this monastery so I didn't select it I I
always wanted to learn more about this
whole kind of like you know you think of
monks you think of like the spiritual
experts in a way at least I did you know
my vision in my head and my publisher of
living with the seal had a relationship
with the monastery just south of Canada
in on 500 acres in the middle of nowhere
and she suggested that this would be a
good place to go that they would allow
me to go and and spend some time there
so I was like cool you know like get me
can I go in a week and and I did and I
went up there really not knowing what to
expect and as it turns out this
particular monastery is world-famous for
breeding and training German shepherds
that's super weird you show up like you
shaved your head right pushed it on
Instagram so you are you thinking you're
gonna go into this Buddhist you know
sanctuary yes I thought I was going to I
thought I was gonna go to and I don't
know what I wanted to go with no I
didn't really know research because I
wanted to go completely just open-minded
I don't wanna have any anyone else's
take on what to expect I wanted my own I
just want to experience and verse you
know have any kind of notions
so I thought there would be like 60
people there I thought monastery equal
community
I thought that it would everyone would
just be walking around silent and all
day we would sit in a circle and think
and there was some of that
there's a lot of sitting around and
thinking but there only there are only
eight monks and most of the day
surprisingly were centered around labor
and I was most of my day was working you
know like mopping cleaning cleaning the
toilets this is like out of weird German
Shepherd caboose like it was like I was
the you know like the rookie on the
football team
were you learning meditation though were
there other people doing what you were
doing there or were you just showed up
and it's you and the monks it was me and
it was me
eight monks eleven German shepherds and
there was a cook that came in a couple
of days a week
I don't want it and one intern yeah they
had an intern uh-huh and that was it and
when I got there the first day they gave
me a quick tour were brother brother
Christopher who was like kind of my
go-to monk and it's kind of a sign to me
is like my senior guy and he gave me a
quick tour and he took me into my room
which was the size of you know no but
not that much bigger than with wise of
your desk and there was a light in a
small little table and he put me went in
my room and he said you know tomorrow
well at 7:15 a.m. we will start with
meditation prayer and reflection when
you hear the bells ring head over to the
sanctuary I said okay it's six o'clock
p.m. right now what do I do for the next
thirteen hours you know like there's
nothing to do and he looked at me like
dead in my eye and he's like you think
and I was like okay so he left the room
notebooks not know zero you see her give
him your phone or you leave that at home
it was like it was like the Russians you
know silenced any kind of phone there
was my phone was it didn't matter that I
had a phone there was no it was like
greyed out so I sat in my room and I'm
like all right I'm gonna try to meditate
you know I taken a Transcendental
Meditation kind of crash course they
gave me a mantra like told me to set my
timer for 20 minutes so I did I got out
my timer and I said it for 20 minutes
and I closed my eyes and I started to
you know try to focus on my word and
immediately you know I'm getting
bombarded with like what am i kids doing
you know the Hawks aren't doing great
you know like all these thoughts are
going through my head and I'm like whoa
the thing has a beat I've been doing
this for a while so I thought maybe well
let me make sure I set my timer I'm like
no I must be just under estimating the
time you know so I went back into my
mantra and start thinking and again I
very hard for me to block stuff out but
after a lot of time passed I'm like
nothing
I'm beeped so I'm like I have to set my
timer and I'll just start over so I took
out my time I opened my eyes and it said
three minutes and 27 seconds so I
immediately calculated how many minutes
I have left 15 days times 24 hours times
you know or 57 minutes and I was like oh
[ __ ] like I'm not this is I mean this is
rubbing I'm not in Kansas like this is
real I'm stuck in this room with no
contact to my family I don't know what
my kids are doing I don't know if my
wife is mad at me for being here or god
forbid something happens I mean all
these fears and thoughts and the clock
slowed down it literally like stopped
and then it was 8 o'clock and I'm like
it's only eight o'clock day one like and
it just really flipped me out and took
me to I want to say a dark place but
like somewhere I've never been before
because I'm gonna I walk water
everywhere we both have our phones right
here yeah I'm never without my phone or
you know I can watch something unfold in
China
real-time on my phone if I want to and
now I'm looking at trees I'm in
isolation and I have 15 days ahead of me
so it was interesting how long did it
take you to kind of acclimate to that
rhythm you know you never know it took
it took until about 10 days literally
where I finally you know what
and I started having all this self doubt
in my head and I started giving myself
outs like saying okay after seven days
I can leave because no one's gonna care
if I went for seven days or fifteen days
I'll say I went for a week like that
sounds good good enough so on day four
I'm like I'm out of here in three days
and I planted these seeds of giving
myself an out mm-hmm and then I got the
day seven and I'm like let me stay one
more day so I can say I got I was over a
week you know and then a day ten I'm
like no Jessie you committed to 15 days
you're here for 15 days start
experiencing and enjoying this and
embracing it for what it is instead of
like fighting it and once I did that and
I was really settled in that's when all
the lessons started to kind of open up
for me and that's when I started to
really kind of you know because we
always give ourselves some kind of oh
maybe it's gonna rain tomorrow I don't
they're wrong yeah well it's kind of
like an ultra like it's so overwhelming
in its breadth and length that the only
way to wrap your head around it is to
break it up into the like okay it's six
I have to get to eight o'clock or I'll
just make it a week and I'll deal with
whatever I have to deal with after that
you know right the only way for your
brain to like process what's happening
and similar to an ultra like you know
you can read before I ran my hundred
mile or I did so much research around
you know at the time not that many
people had ran 100 miles maybe like four
hundred Americans I think is all that I
could identify back then I read every
blog and everything I could about
goal-setting and all this stuff but a
mile 93 when I had six toe nails in my
shoe floating around all the stuff that
I had read and all the preparation it
goes out the window and it's just you
and that's how I felt in that moment
like nothing I read about oh you know
people telling me it's only gonna be two
weeks yeah tell me that at one o'clock
on day two when I'm sitting in the room
and it's there's no one around like the
only two weeks that goes away fat and
then you look at your watching like the
only 17 minutes have gone like time
stops yeah and then you start thinking
what am I missing with my children why
what's the point of this like this is
what am i doing mm-hmm and you start to
flip out so and then but then you learn
about yourself you know like well what
am I missing
what am I not in it what am i doing in
the day you know that why it I'm sure it
makes it very clear the extent to which
you're first of all like addicted to the
device because we're never put in a
position where we have to be away from
it you know and then it becomes so real
like oh my god like I can't I can't
distract myself I can't you know solve
my you know boredom by just watching a
video or scrolling through whatever
social media platform I know and you
know it's interesting even if you out of
a movie for two hours you're separated
from your phone maybe or maybe you're
checking it during slow points in the
movie but the second the movies over you
grab your phone and you respond you feel
like and what happens is I'm you know
everybody knows this but someone emails
you you feel like you have to respond
immediately well that means they control
your time and that's every day times 50
right look every time you get a text and
if you don't need I just emailed you one
Gmail me back and getting away from it
all like one thing I was very aware of
like do I really care that someone is
posting a picture of themselves
drinking a Corona in Mexico right now my
facebook page and like I'm not
responding to it no I don't miss that at
all and I became very clear it became
very clear what is important but also
things that aren't important that I
spend a lot of time on during the day
such as such as TV sporting events I
went during the final during the March
Madness so I probably would have watched
200 hours of basketball you know or
something like that and I didn't miss it
at all I didn't think about it I wasn't
really even curious about it cuz I was
so separated from it and I was I became
super present in all the tasks that I
did and I realized that during the day
I'm rushing to complete a task to get to
the next task so I can do as many tasks
as I can do in a day because that equals
cross it off my to-do list and that
equals accomplish
we're the monks everything was mono
tasking it's like if they if the chore
today was to clean the church or that
which I did a lot there was no times
like when you're done and is perfect
leave the church and go to the next task
you know it's like be fully present
knows with everything that you have for
that task yeah so when the monks come to
go to the monastery they pledge all
their possessions to the monastery so
they have zero possessions and you know
obviously they live a very simple life
but a very full like you know very full
life and a very strong sense of
community I realized how important like
you know community is one thing that I
want to work on at home you know is just
100 years ago was all about community
and now that our worlds are very wait
way smaller and I found at least in my
life so yeah it was just really
interesting to see how happy people
could be with so little and how much
energy mental energy and clarity was
freed up by not having to worry about so
many things that are irrelevant right is
that the biggest takeaway you know what
was interesting for me there was so many
small little takeaway you know that
there was something small little
takeaways for me but for me and it goes
back to we were talking about earlier
that experience is they give you a layer
they give you an edge as you do
different experiences and try different
things you get a different layer added
to rich role he goes up like another
ring on the tree nothing on the tree and
it's something you can always tap into
and and the takeaway wasn't like oh
here's this specific takeaway everyone
knows to be present everybody knows if
you slow down and meditate there's
benefits everybody knows that they
shouldn't be on their phone as much as
we not I'll do it we all we all know all
that stuff and yeah that was all
reinforced
simplicity was reinforced and you know I
love my wife and my kids obviously was
reinforced but when I left the monastery
and the driver picked me up and he said
how was it how do you feel my answer was
proud
it was another layer from me of
something that I said I was gonna do
that was super hard and I was proud of
myself for not giving up a day 7 and
sticking to it
mm-hmm now there are times when my kids
have you know but you know they're going
crazy they're out of control or
something they're having a meltdown and
I definitely found myself to be more
patient and more present and that was a
good lesson but it's it's a layer in me
that I can tap into when I need it right
so when you come back how do you react
l'm eight and do you end up kind of so
you have that extra layer but I would
imagine it's like okay well the phones
back in the picture
like have you reframe your relationship
to the phone for example or do you
slowly just sort of refer back to like
what you were doing before with a little
bit more awareness but perhaps but kind
of essentially being the same dude well
I realized that I wanted a lot of things
that they had but I didn't want to give
up a lot of things that I had and I did
I did gradually it was it was hard to
reenter you know I went from a very
quiet no music no kids no TV everyone's
talking like this
slowly to a very like rambunctious you
know like crazy household with four kids
under 8 that have you know it was hard
it took me a while to and I lost a ton
of weight so it took me like a while to
just get back into the flow and now I
would say that I still am checking my
phone before I get up and but there's
other areas for example when I when I
went around 8:00 to 9:00 or 10:00 at the
monastery all the decisions are taken
away from you so they say that the
average American makes between thirty to
sixty thousand decisions a day it's
exhausting we only have a limited amount
of energy at the monastery all the
decisions are taken away from you you
eat when they tell you to eat you eat
what they give you you wear one outfit I
showered one time I was there
there no one cared there's no there are
notice there's no like well there's not
like you have Netflix Hulu and 8,000
channels and like a short circuit
there's so much you don't even know what
to watch you like [ __ ] it I'm just gonna
go to bed
there are no decisions when that kicks
in the amount of energy that you get is
oh you don't even I didn't know what to
do with myself
I walked 120 miles up and down their
driveway while I was there I had so much
energy and clarity mmm like my to do I
just organized my entire life and I when
I came home the first morning my wife
woke up and we were in the kitchen and
she said to me I'm gonna take the kids
to school I'm like great sweetie you
know and she's like I'm take the blue
car we have two cars I'm like great
take the blue car and then she came
running and she's like nope I decided
I'm gonna take I think I just take the
silver car because I want to maybe go to
Whole Foods and with the trunk space I'm
like great take the silver car and then
she came in a minute later she's like oh
no I'm taking the blue car because I'm
gonna I'm like Sarah do you know how
much energy you just used on a
meaningless decision like you just spend
15 minutes cop debating in your head
what car to take and then I realized
that like we do that all day long and
it's exhausting it's exhausting so how
do you take that awareness back into
your life and streamline things so that
you're you're eliminating a lot of that
decision fatigue so the first thing I
did was I got a journal and I just
anytime I have a thought or something I
have to do I get it out of my head and I
put it on paper now that doesn't mean it
goes away I still have to do it but it's
not I don't have to have the use the
energy to remember it all I have to get
little Ralph an eight-year-old birthday
party for Sunday's birthday I'll just
write it down and now I don't I know I
never have to think about it again I'll
look at my journal at night and in the
morning but I started just dumping
everything out of my head every idea I
keep it with me everywhere I go and it's
just a running list so it doesn't stay
we keep so much in our head and for me
it's worked it's like a to journal
system I have one book where I have all
my thoughts and to do's and this and
that and then on a daily basis I take
out the key things I have to do that
day and take him off the list right and
know what I realized rich if I lose if I
lost the master book with ten thousand
things nothing in my life that you
wouldn't change life would go on I've
often thought like I wonder what would
happen if I just police
selected all my emails and just deleted
all of them because I just there's no
way I'll ever get to inbox zero it's a
losing battle and it creates so much
stress and and anxiety in me like others
I should be getting back to all these
people and it's like I can't imagine I
mean this is this is an epidemic amongst
most people right we're constantly in
this state of anxiety because we're not
able to manage like just our basic
communication when I went off email for
15 days when I came back the first thing
that I said is I'm never going back on
email and I have your oh you have Wow
but it is a goal of mine uh-huh
it is a goal of mine I don't know how
realistic it is in today's in today's
world but how amazing would that be if
you need me you have myself those that
need me have my cell phone mm-hmm that
really need me the owner of the
Baltimore Ravens told me that he is off
email completely yeah well there's
always those ball or guys yeah they can
do it you know it's like it's a
different situation well a lot of people
are going analog now they're just kind
of printing you know the emails out and
keep you know tracking it a different
way but I don't know but it would be
amazingly freeing to do it I'm not there
yet but I know it's like it's a it's a
weird like fantasy I mean look we're the
last generation that knows what it's
like to live without the internet right
like we're we're in a very unique
situation because we grew up without it
and now it's omnipresent and there will
never ever be another generation of
people who had that experience that we
had right so so having like one foot on
one side of it and one foot on the other
side of it like we know what it was like
without it and it is life better with it
you know with all these decisions and
all these complications that we have
probably but I don't know they're
sending a
out like that that I kind of wish we
could go back to if you were to ask my
parents they were or your parents they
would probably say life was better 10 or
20 years ago I I don't know we think
about how our parents got around when my
pet when my mom dropped me off at school
or at play play date or at the park or
whatever and then she went to the
grocery store my father had no way of
getting in touch with them yeah like if
there was an emergency or like oh honey
we forgot can you get an extra loaf of
bread she'd have to come home and put on
the list for next week
there was no way like instant I mean
I've been on a route to get groceries or
whatever and gotten an alert you know
something from my wife being like nope
go pick up our son at the soccer game
immediately and then go to I forgot and
you change your hold on those minute
those moments when you are out of touch
because someone's phone died like it
instills like almost like a panic
exactly so I think there's there's got
to be a balance but it's oh we're
getting bombarded and it's overwhelming
man it's not good for us so when you
were writing this book did you do it in
the same vernacular and style as the
seal book like sort of blog entry like
experiential I mean that would be
something were you doing that when you
were at the monastery going going you
know back to the room every night and
contemporaneously like writing you're
right going on so I struggle with the
book I struggled with it during the
process and you've gone through it as
we've written a book multiple because
first of all I felt a tremendous amount
of pressure after the seal button
because with the seal but I had no
expectation I didn't even really promote
the seal book initially because I was
scared like what if people don't like it
I want to get it you know I don't know
how the game was played you know how the
book game has played big sales week one
and all that stuff to get on the net New
York Times bestseller and there's a lot
of shenanigans there's all these
shenanigans and I was like man I'm not
playing the shenanigans I don't and I
was getting pressure from the publisher
on how to do all that stuff
I don't want to do it so I put it out
let's see if people like it kind of like
how you started your podcast
and then you know if they like it we can
get momentum and winds will build on it
and then because the book was successful
and ultimately went on to be a
best-seller okay how do well now what
the second movies is the first movie
this is a completely different book so I
felt that the whole way every page is it
funny are people gonna there is their
takeaway you know I started like really
analyzing it so it took me a while until
I got into a rhythm and it set up
similar there's you know the time that
it took to get me to the monastery and
kind of what got me there and this
revelation I had on the top of Mount
Washington about time and my
relationship with time which kind of led
me to the monastery in a way and then
there and then there's a 15 day diary
and then there's ten specific takeaways
in the book mm-hmm yeah so similar yeah
yeah I like it but I can imagine yeah
that pressure because that book was so I
mean that book was super successful
living with the seal so now you got a
like you got a top it right or do i yeah
you know I mean I yeah but I mean you
want to but my you know you just
projects like this you know you you have
to have thick skin you have that thick
skin and you're so vulnerable mm-hmm
cuz people put reviews that on Amazon if
you give someone at sixth grade that's
like Rick who's an [ __ ] I know well
and also it's it's such a I mean it's
your experience of the review if there's
a negative review they're kind of
reviewing you as a person you know it's
not like you wrote a novel but it's like
anything in life you're here for huh no
one's gonna be around in a hundred years
you know is that gonna be enough to stop
you the fear that you might get a bad
review is the fear that your product
might get critiqued or someone that like
might not like Zico coconut water or
have a bad flight so we're not gonna
start Marquis Jet you know you have to
go with like the more the bigger the
risk you take the bigger the reward
right III know what your third book
should be you want to live together no
no it's so obvious dude what's living
with Sarah you know what I mean like
such a unique person right and you
always describe her as like you know one
one part Lucille Ball one part Ines
like you know that in and of itself I
mean how your marriage works and and you
know how you guys parent your kids I
mean you know I think would be super
interesting yeah we I I would love that
she's so interesting to live with
because one thing that Sarah does really
really well that's I do terribly is
she's really good at accepting and
criticism mm-hmm and when I get
criticized
you know I'm immediately defensive
probably like most of our listeners are
[ __ ] you what are you talking about
telling me of it you don't know what
you're talking about you get defensive
she takes it in and processes it and you
know and is comfortable with that and
she there's so many buckets of her life
where she does things completely
differently than most people that are
like amazing life lessons I get to live
with that like give me an example well
that's a good example
the way she parents she really props she
really praises the effort she makes it
big I mean I see it every day
emphasizing the effort and not the
result so you know instead of saying oh
you dominated the basketball game which
none of my kids do she says like you
practice so hard and it really showed
today all that hard work keep it up
criticism is another one how she just
how how important product is to her like
I'm a rama rusher I'm like let's put it
out there and we can always fix it and
she is a no I mean she spent she spent
two years working and perfecting her
product Spanx the first product that
came out before she released it she is
working on a product now at Spanx it's
like kind of her secret product and they
were in Italy and they've had all these
teams of people working on it and they
all came the Sara the product everyone
we've tested it we've worn the product
we're so excited about it and says what
can I put it on and everyone's in the
room and the guys flew in from Italy
that have been working on it and she put
on the product and she's like you know
send it back it's 97 percent but
not it's not there and she just you know
I think most people would probably be
okay with that but I don't think you
know Elon Musk would I don't know that
Steve Jobs level yeah perfectionism yeah
you know in a positive way it's like you
know in in looking at it through the
lens of the customer and looking at it
through the lens of the competitor like
yeah maybe everybody else is hot is
comfortable at ninety five percent but
the gold is in the last fight business
company is where it's at because of that
without question right I think I was at
the Museum of Modern Art and I saw yeah
took a picture and texted you I was like
that's so bizarre yeah I know but that
speaks to what you're saying right like
it doesn't that happens because you have
somebody at the helm yeah who's
providing that attention to detail yeah
but at the same time just based on like
you know following you on Instagram like
she also seems like she's bananas she's
bananas which is fun I mean you know she
hurt that and that's another lesson just
like her outlook on life you know she's
had all this business success and she's
done so much for so many people through
her philanthropy and her efforts yet she
has this completely lucille ball side to
her right like you guys traveled and you
get there and she opens up those
suitcase and there's nothing in it she
brought the wrong suitcase or like you
know yeah like the other i mean the
other day i'm in california and
obviously and i called it a say good
night and i was saying you know i'm
exhausted you know i just got i flew in
this today and it was it was 8:00 at
night and she's like you're exhausted
it's only eight o'clock at night there
I'm like it's 11 o'clock like you know I
just got here like you think about China
and it's one of the afternoon I wouldn't
be tired what are you talking about so
she has this other side to her that but
it's playful and it's fun and it keeps
us young so on some well I mean I don't
know if you guys are opposites but you
do come at things in a different way
like and that's something I can relate
to you my wife and I are very different
like
do you make that work in your marriage
just being accepting I think I think I
think a big part in marriage I'm not a
marriage expert for all it's a work in
progress for us and sure for everybody
but if our movies and our heads aren't
aligned if her expectation is very
different than my expectation it's gonna
lead it's gonna lead to disappointment
so one of the things the monks did which
is interesting is every Friday night
they have something called sharing and
all eight of them sit around and they
talk about during the week anything that
anyone has done that pissed them off and
they talked about the expectations going
forward so they're all on the same page
and they all get everything out since
I'm leaving all your [ __ ] out on the
table right and it's something that we
just started doing you know like we've
married for 10 years
and we've never ever ever sat down and
then like okay let's talk about what our
family goals are what our individual
goals are like what's bothering you
about me what's bothering me about you
and now we have this like once a month
minimum sharing session where we go and
it's so helpful man and I realize like
do you get defensive though I do I do
but now but she can hear it she could
hear it but it's part of it and she
absorbs it it's like you know I'm like
yelling at her and she's like that's a
good point sweetie let me process that
and I'll pick you know that thank you
for sharing it but um you know but it's
super helpful and I think so that is
even though we're very different you
know I fruit and bananas only in the
morning and she loves Jesus and you know
we were opposite in and we're opposite
in some of our parenting styles too I
think that's the way to kind of bridge
the gap cuz if we did and she thought I
you know I was gonna act one way and I'm
like what are you talking he never told
me that he never told me that you wanted
me to be asleep at nine o'clock you know
and you and she bottles inside you know
it's gonna ultimately lead down a bad
road yeah I think that's super important
because not only could you be walking
around with totally different mental
pictures
of you know what you think your life is
is you know should be about and where
you're headed you project that onto the
other person and it's all based on
assumption because there's a
communication and I think that's where a
lot of people just get into tons of
trouble yeah I do too and I recognize
that and I didn't recognize it for
awhile I have my own movie in my head it
was different than her movie right
unparent I feel a wee parent you know
what are the differences in how your
parent a good cop bad cop I think a
little bit I think we're aligned in the
fact that we want our kids to see us do
as many things that are hard and
challenging that might result in failure
as possible so when Sarah was a kid at
the dinner table every Friday her father
would ask her brother and herself what
they failed at and if she said oh I
tried out for cheerleading and I felt I
didn't make the team and her dad would
high-five her and he really just
redefined failure as being effort and
not trying versus you know putting
effort in so we try to do the same thing
for example I just I took my son to a
Polar Plunge that the fire department
and Police Department were having a Lake
Lanier in Georgia where we live and on
the way there he was five at the time
and the water's freezing I'm getting him
so pumped up we're listening to Rocky in
the car and I'm grabbing I'm sure like
yelling at him he's yelling at me like
and we get there and they blow the
whistle and everybody runs into the
water except my son who's standing on
the beach a lot like shiver is the only
smart one right and now he's crying and
everyone's looking at me and I'm like oh
my god faster so I went out of the water
and I was like no this is amazing you
got to see I loved it and you got to
cheer me on and thank you for supporting
me and thought it up but he's a shy kid
and it affected him cuz he had to live
with that disappointment he felt like he
disappointed me and that failure for a
year we go back next year same thing
listening to Rocky firing him up they
blow the whistle he's the first one in
they blow the whistle to come out he
won't come out I'm like it's over buddy
we did it get on out and he got and the
lesson was if you stick with it and try
again and now
you conquer it even after you failed
that's a huge powerful lesson right
removing the stigma the stigma sticking
with it you know just using a different
word altogether than failure I mean
failure is just a terrible word yeah
yeah so those kind of things I think you
know we were aligned in and then you
know Sarah's I think I'm probably the
bad cop and she's she's probably a good
gun strike me more as like kind of like
the coach your kids like you're the
you're the coach and they're the team
yeah but you're but I mean adventure is
like a huge I mean this is like infuses
everything that you do right so how does
that like spill down into how you raise
your kids
I'm I just took my son who's eight to
Matt Washington in New Hampshire and we
slept outside in the snow in a minus 40
degree sleeping bag overnight and it was
phenomenal and we trained for a month I
got him a pack we went through it we
talked about the safety he went to we
broke the ice and got water out of the
stream and boiled it and he got to
experience that and you know I said to
him when we were up there you know look
around ladies his name is Lazarus to
look around there's no one out here and
there's no kids out here this is like a
special moment and you know you worked
hard to get here and we I want you to
like we have to appreciate this and like
you know he's like dad this is amazing
and a we had the alone time together
which we have a ton of alone time but I
wanted him to experience the elements I
wanted to experience something that was
hard I wanted to feel victory mm-hm and
he's not super athletic so this is a way
that he can have his own victories and
go and talk about it at school and I
wanted I want it I want him to do
whatever he wants to do but I want to
expose them to as many different things
as he can yeah
how old is he he's eight Wow it was
amazing it's pretty intense for listen
rich my I got lectured before I went you
know how how bad an idea was that went
south you'd be like 1:00 in the morning
he said to me it was pitch dark I can't
even see one inch
in front of me and it's I'm talking I'm
saying it's pitch-dark yeah and he says
dad I have a flashlight but you can't
even see the flashlight you know says
dad I'm cold which is the last thing you
want to hear on the you know it's -5
degrees and I reach over to see where he
is and and and feel his head and you
know just kind of get his temperature
and just see what's what
as I reach over his sleeping bag is
completely covered in snow because it
was snowing right and I said to him get
in your bag and don't come out because
there's no way to get down we're two and
a half miles up and there's no light no
trail this is impossible and there's no
humans around so he woke up at like 9:00
the next morning and everything was cool
and he slept great but it was a moment
of nearby I didn't sleep one minute you
know this could have been a bad idea it
was so bad I'm like I gonna have to put
him in my bag and I'll just bundle up
and but it ended up being fine and he
loved it and we're going back Wow did
you go did you do like a Mount
Washington expedition the year when you
were doing like 2017 of everything I
just remember like on Instagram like you
guys right it was dark and you were you
were with her buddies like in the middle
of the winter
yeah to go climb up Mount Washington it
was a bad idea yeah it didn't work out I
know it did yeah we none of us were
experienced I mean we did have a guide
you were fired up though I was so fired
up and we've got about a quarter of a
mile to the summit but but it was so
hairy out I mean it was like 50 mile an
hour winds and it was minus 30 and we it
was getting dark it was a bat ball we
would have enough time to get down for
it so we aborted about a quarter of a
mile from the summit when we got home I
told my wife like I was so disappointed
cuz I invited all my friends and kind of
guarantee we would get up there and we
didn't and I'm like we failed and she
was like sweetie you know go back next
winter get a tour guide that can help
you navigate them down and train for it
and break your boots in and I'm like
next winter I'm going back on Saturday
because and I did and we went back five
days later and all the same guy same
guys and we saw her and we saw
it and the reason was like there is no I
said to her like there is no guarantees
exactly what we're talking about the
beginning of the podcast there's no
guarantee what next winter looks like
what if I break my leg
next winter what if next winter the
world changes and we can't uptick next
winter I'm going Saturday urgency and
I'm glad I did and check it off and you
guys made it we made it was for now have
you ever done any cold wet like winter
camping no it's a whole different animal
and it's it is it is so it's thrilling
it's like it's it's amazing it's amazing
I had neither do you do you have a
desire to do you know these crazy Alpine
expeditions like Everest and the like
not Everest Colin Oh Brady asked me to
do Denali this year but the dates to
this this summer but the dates didn't
work but yeah not not Everest just
because of the time commitment and the
risk
I'm not I'm not a thrill seeker like
that but I do
I did love Washington I want to do you
know every year as I plan out my year or
my five years that's something on my on
my list every year what else is on the
five year list well I have I don't have
a five year list as far as other than
that and I have a [ __ ] list instead
of a bucket list and on my [ __ ] list
are probably 10 things you know just
things I've always want to ride my bike
cross-country I found the loophole in
the NCAA regulations actually and I have
eligibility to real crew so I want to go
try to make me like the Virginia crew
team you can go back to college and your
your eligibility will still stand
there's a loophole as it relates to crew
specialist crew yes uh-huh
maybe some other sports too so this is
the this is the other book I don't know
if I'm gonna do a book but I am gonna do
it so you're gonna enroll in college
well here's the deal so most of the most
of the high end all of the tie in
Division one sports teams are sanctioned
by the NCAA
and all the elite teams are division 1
teams etc etc as it relates to crew of
the top 20 team some of them are club
teams which are not sanctioned by the
NCAA which means if you take three or
four credits at the school and you can
make the team regardless of how old you
are or whatever because it's not
sanctioned by the league it's a club
team if you're part of the school you
can do it so I can go make the Virginia
crew team which is like I think top 20
team uh-huh and row in the NCAA
tournament or whatever yeah by taking
three credits so it's like if I want to
go rowing University of Georgia as long
as I'm good enough to make the team
I could do it tomorrow right at 50 yeah
you got to do that absolutely if you
wrestle so what happened was I realized
that a friend of mine son who rose the
GW when he was a junior in high school
the way this whole thing came to be he I
was following him and the way they give
out crew scholarships is they get the
elite rowers in high school to a school
and like be you or something they put
him on an ERG rowing machine and they
time them in the 2000 meter that because
it eliminates you know currents and wind
and body weight and all that stuff if
you can row 622 a 625 mm they basically
hand your scholarship so I looked at the
elique the guys that were getting like
6:15 6:20 like the elite elite guys were
like 6-4 185 I'm like that's like my
frame like I'm six three one you know I
could be 185 if I wanted to so I'm like
I got to see if I can row how fast I can
row mm so I'd read that like Cam Newton
broke seven minutes and like throw up in
a bucket like rowing a 615 mm is brill
it's like that's a proper proper athlete
and I was nowhere close
so it became a goal like alright you
know I got a knock a minute I got a
knocking a minute off uh-huh and get my
SATs up a little bit so so you are you
training for that right now it's on my
radar actually I bought two words of
what it's like very George Plimpton you
know well you know it's like
I mean I think it would be how fun would
that be I mean I think super fun super
fun that would go back to college yeah
right so what are we doing after
practice I said to cero and I discovered
this thing I'm like you know what would
you be willing to move to Cambridge
Harvard like let's see if we get a
broker in a Boston that can can get us a
nice little apartment so you can grow
crew your kids are like what you're
doing what but what I am doing rich is
as I turned 50 I mentioned this to you
um you know I have certain things that I
want to kind of semi master that I
always wanted to mm-hmm kind of be good
at but I'm not good at and I'm gonna
bring in instructors around those 50
things from my own birthday present to
myself right you were talking about this
before the podcast so like everything
from like ping pong to what ping pong to
freediving to wake surfing to chess to
ballroom dancing you know just 50
different things I'm gonna try to have
an instructor live with me for a week
for each of those of those disciplines
and see if I can kind of semi master
them to the best of my ability you will
not want to play me in ping pong a year
from now right oh yes I mean a week
you're not gonna be able to master
anything in a week but exposure I'll get
better
yeah and I'll learn a little bit about
about each of those kind of new out you
know disciplines and time will slow down
it is true like it is that weird thing
as you get older like it does go so fast
but when you're when you when you're
trying to learn something new that's
where the clock your relationship with
the clock changes it does and isn't that
all what we all want to do slow down the
clock we do you know and it's weird how
we have this idea of what 50 should look
like like you know I mean dude when my
dad was 50 I thought like well the
students ancient you know and I don't
know whether it's like a generational
thing like that the vitality that you
know 50 year olds have now versus then
or whether it's like a socialization
thing but I feel like I mean I yeah I
don't feel 24 but like I don't feel like
what I
50 was supposed to feel like well you
know what hundred years ago know what
the life expectancy of an American was
like 30 we have a 45 mmm so because we
were lucky enough to be born you know 40
of what v was 60 so 40 years later we
basically have almost double the life
who basically live twice as much life
just because of how lucky we were and at
the current rate if it continues to if
the if life expectancy continues to
expand like that think about this if it
was 45 a hundred years ago and now it's
75 that means that in theory at that
pace humans could live to be 500 no you
shake your head but think about it I
didn't shake my head I was just letting
it sink in yeah now I've hundred well
look at the trajectory look at the
trajectory now maybe yourself but why
not mm-hmm well if they get stem-cell
stuff figured out and they get telomeres
figured out and they get you know I mean
well maybe if you know things are
getting crazy you know in terms of
what's happening with technology so I
feel like nothing's off the table at a
minimum we're gonna turn into some kind
of weird you know cyber hybrid yeah you
know kind of thing
well the flip side of that is I heard
that Stephen Hawkins before he'd
probably the greatest Stephen Hawking
Hawking yeah I'm sorry probably one of
the greatest minds of our generation
right I mean science Minds predicted
that unless humans inhibit and habit
inhibit now I don't know where to go
okay finish okay I'll finish a different
plant get existence on a different
planet mm-hmm that the human race on
earth would be wiped out in 500 years
because of either famine overpopulation
disease war he made that before he died
I believe he revised that prediction to
a hundred years hmm if he's right and we
only had a hundred years of I'm not
talking about us on earth but our
humanity humanity how would that change
the way you live your life
it would change it dramatically and it
would change the way you raise your kids
you know and there's no guarantees I
mean the way the way that the world is
shaping up and you know I could see why
that would be a possible prediction to
make and when you think of it through
that lens it changes the course of the
way you want to live your life and you
know it's just interesting to hear
different theories and DIF different
opinions around time around longevity
and and when you start looking at
through a different lens as we did with
our parents earlier you have a different
appreciation a different urgency a
different set of what's important and
what's not important and then you make
shifts fundamental shifts in the way you
want to live your life and who you want
to spend your time with yeah the idea
that in a hundred years humankind could
be gone is a trip but when you look at
the extent to which you know were we're
over populating the planet and our you
know lack of regard for how to do it in
a sustainable way I think it's a very
real prospect and to reframe it that way
that's super interesting I've never
heard anybody put it that way like what
if in a hundred years there's no more
human beings how does that change how
you look at what you're gonna do today
if you knew that was factual you'd
probably travel more you want to see
more of the beauty of the world you
probably you know won't be on your phone
as much you won't be sitting there
liking and texting and retweeting and
doing all that stuff you know and we
have a vision of what we think it's
gonna be but what if it's not and what
if it was gonna happen what if that did
happen it's fascinating to think about
man and like you know that's the [ __ ]
that happens when you but I've turned 50
no I you know my head it's the pillow
and it's just like oh my god man I've
you know if I do have 30 years left me
personally it's like it just it changes
a lot of things for me and it's a lot
different than my thought
when I was 20 what was your thought
pattern at 20 no consequences for my
actions you know wanted trying to make
money when I was 20 I was laughing at
jokes don't learn funny you know going
to meetings and wanting to get a sale or
sell a Marquis Jack card and I'd be like
you know very often I'd be in a meeting
and I'm like this guy is not my kind of
guy
well you know this is not my kind of guy
and then he would tell a joke and I'd
like uh because I wanted to make it yeah
putting the mask on yeah and it didn't
feel good it didn't feel good in those
situations what does happiness look like
for you now I mean I know you gave a TED
talk about this uh I did it's it's a
lifestyle it's not a decision it's it's
not a happiness as for me looks like a
lifestyle and doing the things that it
really is it's it's a lot of I think a
lot of people look at happiness as a
decision like oh I want to be happy now
and I look at it more of how I choose to
live my life doing things that make me
happy with the people that make me happy
there's so much power behind like the
momentum of our daily habits you know
and you know somebody who's like always
you're always putting yourself in these
new situations like that's very
different from how most people live like
you know they get up they go to their
job you know whether you're living for
the weekend or or whatever you kind of
have your routine and as you age it's
easier and easier to settle into that
and more and more difficult to like
think creatively out-of-the-box about
what the possibilities you know may be
so you know how do you you're going
around you're given all these talks and
talking all these people like what are
you telling them like how are you
getting people to you know to try to
like jackhammer them out of like their
worldview well I think one thing is I
encourage people to put something big on
their calendar every year Circle it
commit to it tell the world so you have
a you know it's easy to tell the world
now with social media so you have
accountability and I feel like if if you
follow through with that big event or
challenge or whatever it is I believe
that the benefits are so
they last a lifetime potentially and it
becomes somewhat addicting so I that's
one thing I really encourage people to
do one very simple thing that I suggest
doing is when I was on top of Mount
Washington with one of my friends when I
took my son he took his daughter there
were four of us I I said to him he's a
police officer and you know one of the
happiest guys I've ever met I assume is
not super wealthy you know he's a works
for the local police department but
mega-happy and I said to him I said
Kevin how many of these trips do you
take we're sitting in our sleeping bag
at midnight it's pitch dark and he said
you know what I take one trip a year
with my high school friends and I'm like
I got to do that because I only see my
high school friends once every five
years that means I only see him like six
more times that's unacceptable I can do
that and then he said I take one trip
one or two trips every other month I
take a trip for myself I just ran the LA
Marathon I did whatever and then I take
a family trip so every other month he
takes a weekend and he circles it and he
does something with his family or
friends or whatever I call it the cabin
rule I'm like if I can't take one
weekend out of every eight weekends of
my life to do something with people that
I love or that I want to do then I'm
living out of balance completely and
that's an easy thing to do and most of
those things don't cost money Mount
Washington there's no it's free to park
mm-hmm there's no cost to go climb the
mountain they need to get gear but you
know most of those things don't caught
and most there has to be physical it
could be like I want to be in a book
club or what I just and and that's a
very easy thing to do but so few of us
do it honestly because why do you think
that is like what's holding people easy
to be it's easy and comfortable to be in
your pattern in your routine it's very
hard to break habit food habits daily
habits for anything and you know and
people are very set in their ways
that's a and then B they're told what to
do it's like we have a universal
playbook you know work your ass off and
take two vacations a year you know I'm
like that's not living for me and it is
nothing
to do with where I am in my life now
when I was 20 I'm doing the same [ __ ]
rich I was doing when I was 21 I run
every morning for an hour I eat fruit
til noon I had the same friends the same
[ __ ] gets me off you know it's like I
just it might be it's just grander but
there's a playbook and the PlayBook is
broken if you look at the playbook you
know with divorce rate at 40 50 % what
40% of it of American males are obese I
think something like 66 not higher than
that 66 percent of American adults are
unhappy there's a Harris survey that
just came out about that there's an it's
like I want to say it's like I don't
have the exact stat but it's I think
like 65% even meaning more percent of
all Americans over 35 don't have over a
thousand dollars in savings I mean the
playbooks broken it's broken then you go
to this monastery where these guys are
living this super simple life and
they're happy and you hear this from
anybody who travels from you know you're
in a small village in Peru or something
like that where people have nothing or
Costa Rica and there's community and
these people are engaged and they're
living longer and they don't have these
diseases and they're not obese and
they're not staring at their phones and
we're so judgmental we have all these
opinions about how people are supposed
to live and we're such a prosperous
nation it's just it's bizarre and
disorienting that that we we've got so
many things so wrong and I'm listen if
people if you love to work 80-hour
workweeks and that that that's what you
love to do that's fine I'm not knocking
it all I'm saying is I think there are a
lot of people and I fall into this area
sometimes myself and I catch myself that
have dreams and aspirations of things
that they always wanted to do but it
wasn't the right time or they didn't
have enough money or they don't have
enough experience it's never the right
time you're never gonna have the right
experience and all of a sudden you wake
up and you're 70 and that's my point and
you're like God I wish I could have done
it
and I think if you were to interview
1,000 elderly people they would all
probably say the same thing like they
had I wish I would have done this then
and if once you become aware of that
there earlier you become aware of that
the full of your life is why do you
think you were able to become so aware
of it it's addicting I did things early
on and I was like I love this I don't
love sitting in my office yeah it was
very simple I like to be told all these
businesses without like sitting in an
office since I did the Kevin rule I
always put it in you know I I ran a
hundred miles in the middle of Marky J I
ran at least a marathon a year in the
middle of Marquis Jet but the other
thing is you're you're like a huge
relationships guy right like you I think
you see and value you know the you know
what relationships are and can be and
that kind of is let's through line that
runs through everything that you've done
like just the fact that you're you're
going and you're hiking these mountains
with the cop or you know you want to go
on a trip with your high school buddies
and you tell that story about like you
know 50 cent was your intern like you
never know who you're gonna be working
with it's all about relationships it is
it is it's always think I think that's
what happens when you get a 980 on your
SAT SAT dude you keep bringing it up you
know what because I got reading for you
I got ridiculed as a kid if you're good
at it yeah there's some pain around
honor they make such a big deal right
what you get any rest et what you get an
arrest 80 I don't even remember where am
i town you know it's a thing it's a
thing yeah
I'll tell you something that's very
interesting that just came into my head
I grew up in a really unique town in my
town it was a small town just like Long
Island in Long Island but in my town we
have two two people that owned or are
owners of professional sports teams is
not that many professional sports teams
we've - we have several people in my
grade of gone to jail
several have committed suicide Bernie
Madoff is from my town hmm the biggest
Ponzi scheme schemer ever everybody in
my town
went through the same school system same
teachers same movie theater same
restaurant same everything I was
thinking about the other day how in the
world did that happen like I had it made
off evolve and some people became
billionaires and some people went to
jail but so many of the people had the
same kind of in some ways opportunity
and I've been trying to kind of crack
the code and get my arms around it I
went to high school reunion a year or
two ago and I was just thinking about
like mmm this whole my town and how this
dynamic of this particular town so much
success yet so much yet the biggest con
artist ever yet some people with amazing
parents or whatever ended up in jail
it's like mind-blowing to me and so what
do you make about I was hoping you'd
have I don't know man
what town was it Rosslyn yeah I think I
think it was just some people got I
think it was just the competitiveness
the decision-making you this came to me
because you're talking about the SATs
and there was a lot of pressure in my
town around where you go to school are
you going to Ivy League school you going
to this school what you getting arrested
eighties you know what I mean I mean I
grew up around a lot of that yeah DC
everybody puts on the they have the
sticker on the back of the car for the
college in the high school and it's all
about that did you care yeah I cared I
was super competitive about it but I was
able to make it work like I was not a
good student when I was younger but I
sorted it out by the time I was in like
tenth grade so I was able to I was able
to play that game huh
yeah then make and make it work but yeah
hyper-competitive that in a
dysfunctional way with the parents as
well you know the right nick is really
damaging so I think you're right I think
all those elements came into play it was
just you know it's a little out there
but I was it just it came into my head
well I just noticed it cuz you brought
it up like three times
thanks for bringing I'm not going too
bad thanks for bringing it to my
attention
and you know what I'm gonna add a pain
point dude I'm gonna surrender it sure I
think you can put it to rest it was 35
years ago it's like get over it already
but it's funny like those are the like
I'm still hung up on [ __ ] that happened
way back then you know it's like you're
talking about like how we're reframing
our lives in terms of time and having a
broader perspective on it and it's like
why do I allow myself to still like look
back on this thing that happened and you
either use it as an excuse or to you
know kind of there's there's like a
weird morbid pleasure and like oh how
painful with that you know it's like why
can't I transcend that you know it's so
true well thank you this is like a
therapy session me I know ever
surrendered it yeah how long even go
hour-and-a-half that's perfect but all
right well let's close it down with and
we've kind of already gone through this
but you know for I always like to try to
end it with you know a little bit of a
lifeline for the person out there who
who's struggling who's like you know in
that job that isn't doing it for them or
you know maybe they just can't get off
off the couch you know whatever battle
you know that person is waging like how
do you shake that person up and get them
to you know take action because I feel
like so much of the podcast is like oh
here's all the information you need but
there's this gap between the information
and the action like the implementation
part of it and that's where people
really struggle yeah I think being aware
of you know if I was gonna summarize it
I would I would say you know think about
the notion of building a life resume put
something on the calendar you know and
circle it I think that's really
important be aware of your time and how
you use it and who do you want to spend
it with and how do you want to spend it
take action and realize that you know
like the clock ticks if you're in a bad
situation at work and I've been there
I've been there you know many times or
in a bad investment or a bad partners
you know yeah
if you it you if you let it go all of a
sudden it's like the longer you let it
go without taking act like an addict
every second that the Attic decides is
not he or she is not gonna go to rehab
the odds of going go down so much right
I mean is that that's a true sure and
it's no different than in in life
decisions like this one of the things
maybe I'll wrap it up with this one of
the things that I take away from that I
write about in my book one of the ten
are two words that changed my life and
those words are remember tomorrow when
you have a split second decision that
you have to make or whatever remember
how that decision is gonna make you feel
tomorrow you want to drop out of the
marathon at Mile eighteen fine how you
gonna feel tomorrow when someone says
how'd you do mmm
you want to take off your shirt and
drink the keel at the holiday party and
dance on the table and swing around and
be the life of the party that's amazing
at the party until tomorrow and you know
those two words if you really think
about it when you have a key decision or
or you're at a critical juncture in
something big how are you gonna feel
when you make this decision tomorrow and
it it comes to peer pressure with you
know decisions with drugs with whatever
and that's really those words really
impacted me you know I'm gonna blow off
the workout today which we went late an
hour and a half you haven't worked out
yet you know it's already the afternoon
how you gonna feel tomorrow about
they're gonna be pissed
mm-hmm right so that's a powerful thing
and any technique or tool or thing that
you can give yourself to give you an
edge and help you be better is amazing
and from me those techniques come
through trial and error trying a bunch
of different things and it's not some
expert telling me what to do yeah maybe
I'll try it but I have to convince
myself that it works you know and that's
been something those words have been two
words that really have worked for me mmm
powerful dude like does that make sense
yeah it makes sense I think I feel make
sense for me I think what you have to do
is you got it yeah
it's like you said you got to find the
strategy that works for you there's a
million ways to do it
you can canvass you know that thousand
successful people and they're all gonna
tell you you know a different approach
to how they do what they do and so when
you you know like read a book or listen
to a podcast it's like here's the
morning routines of the most successful
people well that's great you know like
but they're different right what works
for you what resonates with you that
does come through trial and error and
you've got to find your own groove like
you keep talking about like oh this Lane
that I'm in it's like you got to find
your lane without question the only way
you find that Lane is by trying out a
million hats if someone with a lot of
charisma tells you this is what he he or
she does they might be able to pull it
off because they have a lot of charisma
but if you're introverted it's gonna be
very difficult to follow that advice so
well not only that like if you're like
well Richard Branson does this in the
morning the idea that if you mimic what
Richard Branson does in the morning that
you're going to become put your threads
in is ridiculous and I feel like there's
a lot of disingenuous kind of snake oil
out there
absolutely around selling these kinds of
ideas rather than on getting people to
do the inside work to really figure out
what makes them tick to cultivate you
know that that sense of self that will
ultimately be the most powerful guiding
force you know to set you on the
trajectory that you're meant to be on
now that's powerful and you're right
it's what makes you tick right and and
that only comes through like people want
to they want to they want a short
circuit the inside job they don't want
to go to the monastery for 15 days they
don't want to have to sit at the edge of
the bed with nothing to do because
that's not sexy you know that's hard and
that's uncomfortable but if somebody
does want a side step that you're
ultimately short-circuiting your
ultimate potential and success because
it is that inner regard that ultimately
will unlock what it is that's unique
about you that's going to be your like
ultimate success equation I totally
agree with you I think we did it dude I
love it great
yeah ready to go to the tent alright now
let's do it awesome so thanks so much
man I appreciate it that was that was
super cool to talk to you if you're
diggin on Jessie you can connect with
him online at 100 mile man at the one I
was out 100 mile man yeah on both
Twitter and Instagram same Twitter tool
living with them living with the monks
living with the monks yeah the monks
coming out thank you so much a check
that out and of course made of Denali
calm yeah you can go to go to may tip
tonight if you're interesting the
Chancellor just go to Jessie its lair
calm / boundless sea also will take you
there yeah thank you so much for that
rich and awesome just appreciate you
having me man thank you I really enjoyed
it
yeah cool thanks dude we'll do it again
sometime Thank You Man peace
[Music]